we saved it for the last minute to go oh
maybe we should call a data vendor and
see if we can subscribe to some of these
data feeds which was
an absolutely deadly mistake
[Music]
rachel carpenter thank you so much for
being on my show how are you i'm great
how are you doing thanks for having me
ah of course it's great to have you i'm
very excited to hear about the story of
entrenio
and uh going i think all the way back to
2012 right i heard you know another
podcast mentioned
starting out in a pretty interesting way
and going through the journey of
understanding the different limitations
and
working in the in the financial services
space and running a high tech company
but but let's go all the way to the
beginning who's rachel carpenter and
and why start a high tech venture
great question rachel carpenter was
actually originally a musical theater
major
believe it or not and ended up founding
a data company
which is a wide swing um but i grew up
in wisconsin
and i went to university wisconsin
madison
and i ended up getting uh dual degrees
in finance and entrepreneurship
and um the part of
what i went through in college was
recognizing that i never wanted to work
for somebody else ever again in my
entire life i had a pretty bad
college level job so i knew i wanted to
be an entrepreneur i didn't know exactly
what i wanted to do yet
um and so i met my co-founder while i
was in college
he was a cpa and i was studying finance
so we had a lot of background in that
space
and the original business concept that
we decided to go after was
actually an online valuation engine so
to do business valuations in a sas
business model we wanted to build a
software online
where to start you would just kind of
type in a ticker of any
stock you were interested in and it
would tell you it would run a
valuation and then tell you is this
stock overvalued undervalued is it a
strong buy or sell
we wanted to kind of build this stock
app this investing tool
um and so i came from a background that
was not technical at all
um but i'd always loved math and i kind
of fell in love with finance because of
that and that's why
i studied that so part of what we went
through was recognizing this is very
complex
if we are going to build a stock app
like this we probably need to learn how
to program to get it off the ground on
our own
um and so i took a year and between my
co-founder and i we learned ruby
uh for the back end and some of the
front-end programming languages
that we needed to get this thing built
and so i went through this journey of
teaching myself how to program i was
sleeping on a couch we were making no
money
it was very uncomfortable and we ended
up building this thing
the problem was that we were illegally
screen scraping data from 10 000
websites
because wait so so before we get we get
into all this illegal fun stuff
it yeah that decision to go and and and
teach yourself how to program you and
your co-founder
it's very unusual in the sense that you
know a lot of the stories that i hear
and that i meet are
you know entrepreneurs they might not
even be coming from the tech background
or the computer science background but
they have this great idea
that could be a software solution and
then they go and they
find people to build that for them but
they don't necessarily teach themselves
how to code i'm a coder myself and i
advocate for learning how to code but
but tell me about that that critical
moment where you're deciding to take
that whole year
a very expensive year not just because
you're not making any money but because
you're
you want to get moving with your ideas
and you're choosing to teach yourself
how to code
yeah that's a great question and and i i
tend to honestly not recommend it in
most cases
it i mean you you know this right it
takes a decade plus to really become a
proficient engineer
and with most technology startups you
have a short window to really beat the
competition and get your product off the
ground
so you don't have time typically to do
that um
and then in nine out of ten cases i
would say don't learn how to program go
find a technical co-founder go find a
team that can do it for you
because you would be surprised how long
it takes to get really really
good and i didn't get there right i got
dangerous enough
to get this thing together but my cto
today still tells me
he's like when i took over it was there
was just skeletons left and right
underneath the rug
with the kind of code that i was writing
because i wasn't classically trained and
i only had a year under my belt
so i don't recommend it in most cases i
think in our case
what we were building was so iterative
and we didn't know where we were gonna
end up with it
and it was so financially complex
understanding how to do a discounted
cash flow is hard enough with just
for financial knowledge um and then
figuring out how to program that and
turn it into an app is a whole different
story and so
in rare cases i think if the if the area
that you're working in
is super complex and requires domain
expertise
it can make sense and you can actually
move faster
in our case like we would have literally
had to have had a cpa
over the shoulder of an engineer and
that doesn't work very smoothly
so there's unique cases like ours where
it did make sense
the caveat there is that i had to give
it up eventually once we got this thing
to the point where we were moving
we hired engineers who had tons of
experience and could really take it to
the next level
so if you are in the one out of ten
where it makes sense to learn
you you do have to recognize that you
have to give it up essentially
right okay so it's 2012 and you're and
now you're you're running this iterative
business you're figuring stuff out along
the way
and you reach the first roadblock where
you find that you're
illegally scraping data online so talk
to me about that junction now
yeah so any any application you're going
to build in the fintech space the raw
materials of that industry are data
right i mean everything runs off of data
we needed stock prices financial
statements earnings estimates
economic data comps we need it for for
all the stocks in the universe
of the united states and so you know you
can go to places like yahoo finance or
different companies like that to kind of
scrape things down but that's a you
can't publish a product that way because
there's terms of service
um and so we were we were kind of
scraping for a while to get our
prototype though but when we really
wanted to launch this thing publicly
we saved it for the last minute to go oh
maybe we should call a data vendor and
see if we can subscribe to some of these
data feeds which was
an absolutely deadly mistake
because the companies that we had to
call were bloomberg capital iq
thomson reuters these huge huge
companies and
to put it in perspective for the data
that we needed to launch our app it was
going to cost anywhere between 60 and 70
a month to get started so remember i'm
on a couch i have no money
i've just spent this horrible year you
know dragging myself through the dirt
trying to get started
it was it ended everything for us
instantly
there there are no economics that work
out for a startup at that stage
to raise even raise money enough to
support a 70 000
a month data expense so we were pretty
pissed off to be honest
it was not a fun day so you find
yourself with your co-founder it's been
a year of struggling and running this
iterative business you finally reached
some sort of product that you're happy
with and you're going
to these data vendors so what's next do
do you just give up do you
do you pivot where do you go from there
we got mad
which was a good place to be and
sometimes that can be the best start of
something even better
we got really really angry about all the
time we had spent and so
the analogy that i use to describe this
this point in the journey is that
we realized do we want to be in the car
business or do we want to be in the gas
business because that's a big choice to
make we've recognized here anybody that
wants to build a car or a fintech app or
some type of solution for financial
services
they're going to need fuel it's going to
be data but if it's that expensive and
that restrictive
for us to get our hands on it maybe
we've uncovered a much bigger problem
here
an opportunity to kind of reinvent the
supply chain of how those data feeds are
made available um
and so there was kind of two things that
happened we realized maybe we should
think about data as a business instead
because we literally can't move forward
unless we solve this problem and then
the second piece that came together for
us
was this thesis that is
definitely becoming true true and true
every single year that we're on this
journey
but the future of financial services is
very technical
you know engineers are flooding wall
street every bank is hiring a 19 year
old data scientist
right now every hedge fund's becoming a
quant fund and that technical
transformation of the industry is huge
but these data providers aren't prepared
for it right if you want to consume
financial data
most of these large data vendors don't
even have sdks they don't have software
development kits for you they have
horrible documentation
their developer tools are awful but we
knew that there
there were engineers and innovators out
there that had ideas
just like us for an app or a tool that
could bring the industry forward
if we could find a way to make data more
accessible to them with the tools they
needed
we could serve that developer market
really really well
right at a time where it was about to we
thought explode within financial
services
and that's exactly what happened and so
when are we in the timeline of in terms
of years
what are we talking about now so 2012
and 13
we were building the engine that we had
to
kill and in 2013 was when we realized we
couldn't afford the data
2014 was the year that we really started
thinking about data as a business and
doing research and figuring out how we
could start building our own data feeds
um so 2014 and 2015
we were programming a lot we were
building our technology we were getting
our first couple of data
feeds built and then it wasn't until
2016 that we really launched publicly
so all this time 2014 2015 you're still
work you're still the coder you're still
the developer
iterating through understanding okay now
let's pivot and go into a new business
wow
that's pretty cool yeah yeah yeah that's
very very cool
so my next question was going to be then
now you're in 2016
what have you learned over those four
years overall about
about the financial tech technology
services world so you mentioned the
analogy to
to the cars and the fuels and you can
either be building the engine you can be
building the data that's fueling it
but but for somebody that's not coming
from the fintech space what are some
great insights that you have from there
yeah so some things that we've learned
is
that you would be wildly surprised
how far behind this industry is
technologically
the for example bloomberg is kind of the
household name if even if you're not in
finance you probably know what a
bloomberg terminal is or you've heard of
the company bloomberg
that terminal is built on 14 million
lines of fortran
fortran which is a programming language
that the oil industry
stopped using 15 years ago but
this critical piece of infrastructure
that's used by
hundreds of thousands of traders all
over the world is built on fortran right
i mean that's just an example of
how these big big companies can't move
quickly even if they wanted to compete
with a company like us it's the classic
innovators dilemma
and it's not even just in the data space
i mean you can apply that to lending you
can apply that to consumer banking
to um you know credit cards to insurance
to any fintech vertical
it's the same thing they all have their
example of the bloomberg fortran
issue and it's this legacy
infrastructure where the fintechs are
coming in and trying to
to break that apart and modernize it but
it's not an easy task because
you're also talking about an industry
where you've got a bunch of people who
are really stuck in their ways um and so
convincing them to use new technologies
is not
easy right and obviously converting for
it's not feasible to convert 14 million
lines of code of fortran to
the equivalent of today's you know
python and javascript or ruby
it's that that's a challenge on its own
so so how do you go about doing that so
you're in 2016
you're starting to to create these data
streams yourselves
and and then we'll we'll end by fast
forwarding to 2020 where now you're
allowing developers
actually to to play with this data but
what does that process look like
so i'll tell you a story about the first
data feed that we built because it'll
help you understand how we approach
building our data products um one of the
core values that's true to our company
is automation
right we're like we'll never use humans
to do any of this like there has to be a
way to automate it
and that and by having that foundation
it means we can spend more resources
towards making great tools and we can
keep the prices down and make it
accessible
the more we automate the less money we
have to spend on that the more money we
can divert in other ways
so the first data set that we ever
looked at building was just financial
statement data
and so you take you know there's all
these 10k reports that are filed at the
sec
but no two companies file their
financial statements the same way
so if you just went to the sec and tried
to pull that data down
oracle might be reporting cloud
computing revenues hardware revenues
software revenues
the accountants over at apple just put
revenues so there is no way
to actually compare apples to apples
between companies
or even over time periods because
companies change their lines of business
and so there's this mess of data it's in
a language called xbrl
which is an offshoot of xml um and it's
this really nerdy accounting programming
language that not too many people know
about but we're experts in it
because we said wow there's got to be a
way to use machine learning
to clean that and so what the large
companies like bloomberg do is they have
10 000 people overseas that are manually
normalizing all that data
we took my co-founder who was a cpa
between the two of us both had
engineering skills
and programmed that cpa knowledge into
an engine that learns from itself over
time gets smarter
and we take an algorithmic approach to
cleaning all that data so
with the two of us our data feed number
one with the two of us we were able to
build that equity financial statement
data feed
with two people in an algorithm um and
to this day it's still the highest
selling data set
on our entire platform and so that's
been our approach right
where where is the actual root source of
this data a lot of it's at the secs and
stock exchanges different places like
that can we go straight to the root can
we clean it and pipe it through in a
much more efficient way
um as automated as we can and build
great developer tools around it
and so that's what we so what is that
what does that mean to build great
developer tools around this data so give
me some
you know ideas of where where's somebody
like myself or any young entrepreneur
who could be using this data
to create some meaningful products yeah
so we've got a sandbox environment we
can get you api keys within 30 seconds
which is pretty unprecedented if you go
talk to any of the large vendors
they're not getting they're not going to
be that fast so we'll get you api keys
we'll get your sandbox access you can
use
software development kits in over six
different major languages
we've got test environments we've got
jupyter notebooks that you can pop open
and start playing around with the data
widgets that you can test out with just
tons of tools chat support seven days a
week
we just make it easy and i think a huge
a huge reason for our success is that
our company was built by developers for
developers so we actually understand
we were trying to build our own app
right we know exactly what it what it
takes
to get off the ground and what's
interesting is a lot of these large
vendors that we compete against have a
major conflict of interest they're
terrified of people like you
and me because they know we could build
a better app than them
and so if they open up those apis and
those raw data streams
might somebody maybe build a better
bloomberg terminal so what they do is
they slap these restrictions on that's
why we got quoted
as much as we did anytime an engineer
comes to them and says i want a raw api
data feed they're not in a position to
do it because it could cannibalize
a whole part of their revenue stream so
we've taken the stance of saying we want
you to build something cool with this
data
we're never going to be in the analytics
or app building space we're just the
plumbers
and our goal is to get the data into the
hands of these innovators as fast as we
can so they can build awesome stuff
with it no that makes perfect sense but
i have to ask so you're eight years into
this journey
and coming from a very different
background than a tech background
why stick to financial services what is
it about this industry
that that takes you in some way that you
said okay
i'm gonna solve this no matter what even
if it's gonna take four years of
bootstrapping
and writing code myself you know there's
there's kind of two answers to that the
first is just what i went through right
a year of my life
i'm angry right and then like there has
to be a better way to fix this
you know i want to solve this problem
for other people and i'm
pissed off that i i learned the hard way
hopefully for everybody else so they
don't have to learn that way
so that personal attachment to just that
time that i spent like
don't get me wrong there's lessons there
i'm glad i went through that experience
but
it shouldn't have had to be that way
those resources should have been
available to me
and so there's that that personal story
of what i went through
and then also just the pure
excitement of watching our data come
alive inside of some
really cool stuff i mean our clients are
building
chat bots ai investing platforms they're
their own trading terminals you know
risk analytics software mobile apps for
investing
some hedge funds we don't even can't
even see what they're doing with do some
you know deep learning models there's
awesome stuff and we get to be the fuel
behind of that and so we just get to see
the little phrase powered by intrinio
at the bottom of this next generation of
apps and so we get to feel like we're a
driving force
behind changing an industry that's
really far behind
technologically so it's fun
so you are the fuel so you are the fuel
to this whole new 21st century
generation of tools
that allow others to build apps based on
this data right so
so anybody who wants to build a chat bot
or or a any ai
machine that allows me to to invest
better or get more information
you're supplying that information
because otherwise it would be very
restrictive through
the bloomberg terminal or the the likes
of the giants right
that's the basic premise here exactly
you nailed it
welcome to the sales team right you're
hired
very very cool so so now it's 2020 and
one of the things that we mentioned
right before starting this is that you
are now getting this out there to as
many developers as possible you're
you've partnered with stanford to
provide
stanford students with uh with it with
the data to play around with right and
that's definitely something that i'm
i'm excited to look at myself but but
what is sort of the vision for this in
the long run besides just licensing the
data
yeah we want to be the number one go-to
data provider for anybody
doing something innovative in financial
services sometimes that is big companies
right we have some
huge hedge funds and institutions that
have projects or tools they're building
but it's more fun when we're selling to
the guys in the couch that are building
something cool
so we're expanding constantly the types
of data that we provide in multiple
different directions right so we're
going
deeper which means what else at the sec
can we extract can we extract risk
factors can we go
get different types of data how can we
go deeper here in the united states
to deliver more us-based data feeds and
then there's broad right which is can we
go to different countries these
financial filings are everywhere in the
world um
most of them are digitized and
structured and publicly available
um so where can we take this tech that
we've built apply it and have a global
set of fundamentals and other types of
data
we have global pricing data but the
fundamentals and the financial
statements is
something we'd like to expand on so
we're going deeper in the united states
with different types of u.s data we're
going broader internationally with data
and then we're also starting to branch a
little bit outside of the quantitative
into the qualitative
so obviously there's been a lot of
advancements in natural language
processing
over the past two years gpt-3 coming out
we have a lot of demand from our
customers who say you're giving us all
these great data points
that are quantitative but could you give
us some qualitative information could
you help us search through the filings
and get other information that way and
so that's kind of where our r d efforts
are focused right now is
how can we start to reimagine maybe we
don't just have to be a quantitative
data provider maybe we can start
delivering some intelligence to our
clients that is qualitative as well
so those are some of the areas that
we're exploring and where we're headed
next
that's that's very very cool so if you
could go back now to 2012 and talk to
rachel back then
who's still bootstrapping through that
first like first iteration of building
this engine
what what are some high-level things
that you would tell her
from the experience that you've gained
over the over the last eight years
you know that's a tough one because i i
could write a book
about the mistakes that i've made i'm
keeping track of them and i might do
that one day
but i learned from all of them you know
i'm happy that we took the path that we
did it took
those early pivots for us it took us
solving a bad problem to find a better
problem to solve
so i wouldn't change anything but i
think just to give myself a little
reassurance to say i always use the
phrase the roller coaster goes back up
again
there are so many times when the roller
coaster goes down and it can feel like
it's time to quit pack up the bags go
get a nice job
have health insurance different things
like that um
and it can be it can be easy to get down
when the roller coaster goes down but
um it always goes back up again so that
would be something i would reassure
myself
um about because there are definitely
some challenging times early on
yeah i love that you know 20 minutes go
by so fast but but it's it's so
inspiring for me to always hear about
these journeys
especially the eight year journey that's
that's incredible
you know a lot of investors when they
look at a pre-seat or receipt company
they look at the founders and they're
asking themselves you know is this a is
this a founding team that i'm i
am able to see them going through an
eight-year journey of rollercoasters and
and you know that's a that's a very hard
question to answer a lot of the time
especially you know today's generation
that we're so you know we keep changing
our mind and moving from one place to
another
so i think i'm getting a lot of
inspiration from that so rachel thank
you for thank you for sharing the story
with me and with
everybody that's listening here and i
really appreciate you coming on before
we finish
i have to ask you the most important
question three words that you would use
to describe yourself
definitely feisty i get i get told i'm
feisty a lot uh
i'm definitely fast i'd say feisty and
fast
um and probably loud i get loud a lot
too
kind of like a steam engine
feisty fast and loud i love it rachel
thank you so much this was really really
great best of luck with intrinio
i look forward to trying and playing
around with it myself and spreading it
with the stanford community
but it sounds like you're doing a great
service to the to the fintech sector
uh i'm very excited to see where it goes
thank you so much for having me